in this modern age I am the one who runs
from all spoilers a fan used to a single
instant survive
the wine what happened you want to watch
a season finale yeah yeah yeah and now
Game of Thrones so no keep it together
keep moving let everyone talk about that
game of Thrones uh you've got this piece
of King then get out oh just don't talk
to Jerry he's not here is he sick oh
please let him be sick I mean not like
serious sick but just
dude look I know you're gonna want to
tell me about the episode I didn't see
it so we can talk about it tomorrow all
right just this doesn't give anything
away but it was one of the best dude
come on I gotta get some water
all I'm gonna say is think red wedding
but redder can't believe I killed that
character I know that was such a twist
and a major plot point I know that
changes everything
how crazy is that and I didn't think he
was gonna be the bad guy I never thought
those two were gonna sleep together and
they did I am just so glad no one told
me about this before he washed it she is
before we get into it today let's just
talk about it and get out of the way
Game of Thrones last night right lost my
damn mind when that happened lawsuit I
got him I'm nuts
I know I know yeah Ben you okay buddy my
ears are right now catch up with you
guys later
that's weird
hey buddy sent you those emails can you
look down for me
yeah no problem Thanks you're right on
that sir please go online go online okay
message sent I wonder what's going on on
Facebook get a quick check wow that is a
lot of notifications watch the timeline
if I could just see part of the screen
no no no bed a bad idea bad idea
wonder what's up on reddit man not good
hey mr. game of thrones himself let's go
over beep I be starting the beginning
like when they would say hey you shoving
a bit there hey wait I'm not the White
Walkers in there the blue walkers
stay back stay who are you and what do
you want water give me that give it over
you know who is this guy
we're Shh you haven't seen it yet have
you it's not my fault I had a little too
much Merlot last night I got sleepy
wait what episode are you on did you get
to the part with the dress they haven't
seen it yet the episode the show the
show oh so pure look we need to get out
of this place is not safe no we're not
going anywhere
too risky out there
throw and spike in your hand hello
everyone this is me
as I walked to my car that day I thought
a lot about life
and love
but most importantly I vowed to never
drink too much or alone on a Sunday
night